9-1-1 quelle est ton urgence
bonjour es-tu là
papa j'ai frappé quelqu'un
et je l'ai laissé je l'ai laissé là
oh mon dieu ne le dis à personne je
ne pourrai jamais faire ça je peux te garder
en sécurité si personne n'en entend parler
le garçon que vous avez frappé ce matin est le
fils de Jimmy Baxter,
le chef de la famille criminelle la plus vicieuse
de la ville,
qui que vous soyez, où que vous soyez, vous
serez trouvé.
J'ai besoin d'une faveur sans poser de questions.
[Musique]
nous allons grand, nous allons grand une fois que je fais de
mon mieux.  un ami vient de me jeter dans le grand
bain, j'ai ça,
je ne pense pas que tu aies
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien,
je te promets que tout ira bien